Gucci Westman
(audience cheering)
Aww.
There is no one more renowned and talented-
in the beauty world.
I'm talking, like you did every Vogue cover
for years in a row, like every single issue.
I mean, that's crazy.
Yeah, that was wild, and I...
That was some...Yeah
Well
Ah, crazy times.
And you now have your incredible company
Westman Atelier,
and your packaging is so lock.
These are so amazing.
And listen, we could all use a little makeup lesson
every now and then.
I was watching 'til late at night
your a recent tutorial
where you come out in your bathroom
and you show up a little, like,
you know,
A mess
You know, I mean,
you're the most beautiful woman ever
but you show up like very real.
You've got some redness, you've got a little puff.
You're like, I'm just, I'm having, I'm having that kind
of morning and what you do in six minutes.
It's insane!
And I have to say watching that tutorial
I felt like I can do this.
So I love that a star makeup artists can help anyone see
that they can do it too.
And one viewer really wants your help actually.
And her name is Colette and she's here.
(audience cheering and clapping)
Thank you.
Collete, tell us about your makeup dilemma.
So,
thank you for having me.
I just, I just turned 51.
So I, I know how to apply mascara
and I do add a little lip gloss
in the morning, but that's it.
I really never learned how to apply makeup.
So, please help me.
Well, you have the best in the business
and Gucci is gonna help you achieve
the ultimate natural summertime glow
and she's here.
So, what are the the tips, Gucci.
Okay
Keep chatty
First off Collette, I'm gonna start
with our vital skin foundation just evening out any redness.
So I always have this approach
of mixing two shades of foundation.
So that way you maintain the integrity of your natural skin.
We have so many tones in our skin
and it really is just to quickly
correct those areas where you need
a little extra.
I want her skin looks nice.
Not like, Oh, her foundation looks nice.
I like that differentiation
that its not the foundation looks nice,
it's the skin looks nice.
Yeah, it's the skin
and I really am super into this word, skin minimalism .
You know, it just makes me feel
like you don't need so much stuff.
We don't need to use a million things.
We need to use the things that are effective
and that will make us feel more confident.
And I have like, you know,
it's all about multitasking and using products,
Like how will you really use them.
And that's, you know
Wait!
Take me through this powder
because I watched you doing it
on the tutorial last night.
Take me through that.
So I have this approach that I liked,
I always envision, how do children look
in the summertime
when they are bronzy,
and they just look well.
So I always use kind of the bronzer in a horizontal fashion
under the eyes on top of the eyes, the forehead.
I never go really below the cheekbone too far
because then again, it becomes too much the same tone.
It's all about kind of correcting the tone
where you don't want it adding color back in
where you do want it.
And, and then, you know, just thinking, how do kids look?
Where did they get sun?
They get sun
like sort of more here
Here
and it looks so gorgeous and not made up.
I'm gonna say something else, which is when you're
with the top hair colorists in the world
those colorists always talk about children's hair.
Yeah.
Because they get these natural highlights that you lose
as an adult.
Yeah.
So the fact that you're talking
about children's skin is so revolutionary to me, Gucci.
So now I'm adding super loaded, tinted highlight
which is a really nice warm
it's a warming kind of radiant
highlight.
So it gives you definition.
It gives you warmth and it gives you luminosity
which I kind of feel like it's the closer
like when you don't have a lot of time
and you feel like,
Oh, there's just one more thing I could use.
This gives you that.
'Cause it's easy to use.
I created the brush, the blender brush that goes
with it and it's packed with active ingredients.
That's why we called it super loaded.
So now I'm going to add a little bit,
'cause Collette mentioned that, you know,
you want to understand what to do in your under eye area.
So one tip is you can add, this is our new highlighter.
It's called nectar
and lit up
and you can add it really anywhere
you naturally would like to catch extra light.
So it's all about kind of like,
Ooh, where do I want more glow?
And then I'm going to give you a pop
of a cheek because we need to add the color back in.
I think I might even go with Poppit
which is looks super bright.
And there's so many different things that you can do
with blush.
And it depends on, you know, the area
of application and now I'm going for like a summer
like you look super well rested
and you're doing a lot of yoga
and meditation and oxygen inhalation and all those things.
And then this is our face trace.
And it's a contour, you know, to give yourself a little bit
of definition on your eye socket
You did Gwyneth Paltrow for her wedding, right?
I did.
Ooh!
So now I'm going to add our newest launch
which is a lip treatment.
It's called squeaky clean liquid lip balm.
And this color is called pipsqueak and it treats your lips.
It's packed with a hobo oil, argon oil,
all of these really nice oils,
just that will nurture and hydrate your lips,
and it feels really nice and pillowy and,
and when you can just use your lips around
So Collete,
do you like that?
I mean, it's like still looks like you
(audience clapping)
Perfect!
Holy cow!
That's why you're Gucci Westman, man!
Darn it, drop the mic!
All right,
Collette, what do you think most importantly?
I just love how natural it looks
and I just feel like I could maybe follow those steps
and achieve this.
I mean,
that's not hard, right?
'cause it wasn't..
Yeah. Just step by step.
And it's just like, you literally,
you don't need that much time and it's just intuition.
Do you mind if I share
that six minute video that I just watched last night
on our website?
No, of course not.
Okay. Cause it really shows how intuitive this is
and what Gucci does with her own hands and her own products
and it's like a little mini master class
and how attainable this is.
Collete, I thank you so much.
Thank you.
You were already so beautiful.
But wow.
Gucci. Gosh, darn it.
God, you're so good.
All right.
Be sure to check out the Westman Atelier Collection
we're gonna be featuring on our website.
I suggest you get the whole line
because you can do your whole face with it
and pick up the new
squeaky, clean liquid lip, balm.
And Colette, I'm gonna send you home with the whole line.
So you don't have to worry.
(audience clapping)
How am I going to do this and get this?
It's all been taken care of.
Oh my goodness.
Thank you.
Well then good, we're done.
(upbeat music)